everyone this is given from the chess
website calm and today we're in round
eight of our coverage 2017 at Grand Prix
in Geneva we have this round and the
next one and we will have a champion in
the third leg of the Grand Prix series
our competitors today both in the
running still for the title why it's
going to be played by Yana punished and
blacks going to be played by it Levon
Aronian so going to get started
pawn to c4 Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and
this is the English opening and getting
into the four Knights game that we saw
earlier in the tournament which before
this tournament we where Lee see this
opening and then in the sternum we've
already covered two of the game so far
where we've seen this pawn to g3 getting
ready to fianchetto on the kingside the
board very similar to opening we saw
before pawn d5 after the capture then
Bishop to g2 the previous game we looked
at we solve the bishop coming down here
to c5 not the main line in this
particular game that you're looking at
Levon Aronian decide to go more of the
main line and that is knife to b6
castle on the kingside for white and
then Bishop to e7 get it ready to castle
for black on the King side as well white
plays pawn to a3 couldn't if you want to
stretch a little bit further with pawn
to a4 but decides to go ahead and keep
things a little closer to home with pawn
to e3 pawn to a5
extending a little bit on the Queen side
for black and in pawn to d3 so you can
see that White's plan is not to push up
too far in this early position Tess on
the Kings side and then Bishop to e3
there's not a ton of options that
White's giving himself he's kind of
blocked off a little bit as far as where
he can move a pawn on b2 that's kind of
stopping the bishop from going anywhere
to this side of the board the Queen
could definitely come to C 2 if you
wanted to could play just Bishop to b2
but decides to go and play Bishop to e3
which is going to stop him from pushing
forward with his epon for just a while
so Bishop to e3 and the Bishop to e6
both sides just getting their pieces
involved into the game rook over here to
see one controlling the semi open file
and then
pawn to 84 so pushing a little bit on
the queenside more than i would
particularly like from from blacks point
of view because you can easily just have
the bishop take on b6 that night is now
defending this pawn as well as this rook
but you could have the bishop take on b6
and then after the pawn recaptures black
has double pawns on the B file don't
necessarily like that from black but
then the ser of the board and you have
another pawn next to it you can actually
push and have good control but on the B
file you just don't see as a good
success especially getting into the in
game with a double pawn but then from
here you could just see pawn to e3 or
even better for white I think is just
taking here on a for the rook is now
attacking it but the bit or the Queen
here on d1 is protecting it so it seems
like he's going to be giving up material
and it has a double pawn structure here
so not my favorite place of this pawn
here to a4 but Yohn decides to go ahead
and not take here on b6 but instead play
Knight to d2 so very very obvious that
he wants to just keep his pieces back
build up a particular position maybe
he's been looking at for a long time and
then continue from there this does open
up the door for the light square bishop
to attack if he wants to
as soon as Levon Aronian saw this he
decided to play pawn to f5 so you kind
of saw an opportunity to push a little
bit have a strong attack he could have
easily played Knight to d5 say I don't
want the bishop now taking on d6 so I
would consider this playing it safe
Knight here to d5 but decides to be a
little bit more aggressive and play pawn
to f5 weakening the key inside the board
but really starting to attack his
opponent saying that he can maybe cramp
the position from wipe now in only now
white decides to go ahead and take a
bishop takes on b6 see the pond
recapture now the knight takes here on a
4 and then Bishop to g5 so white has
cramped position and so you kind of see
what both sides are looking to do now
these pawn structure on the B file is
even worse than before because there's
no pawns on either side of it so
although white is up material just on
the pond side he's up even a little bit
more because these pawns just don't do
as well it's going to be even easier for
white to really attack these especially
if this Knight moves then that pawn is
going to be hanging to this bishop right
here White's really trying to get out of
this cramped position blacks trying to
use his aggressive placement right here
double bishops on board also has kind of
the central pawns in the center and he
could easily get both of his rooks in
his queen involved into the game his
knight over on the a file not doing a
whole lot right now his knight on the D
2 square is not very centrally involved
and is rook here on f1 it's going to
take a while before can get involved so
Levon Aronian really needs to keep up
the pressure
as soon as white can't start to open up
the game trade down some material he's
going to have a better in game than
Levon Aronian is so white plays Knight
to c3 doesn't want to have it on the a
file once to get it back involved into
the game and pawn here to e4 so pushing
that strong attack that Levon Aronian
has seeing if he can have his opponent
crack rook to be one once to get it out
of the way of the pin the bishop here on
g5 is pinning down this night so he
wants to be able to move this knife
freely defend the square or attack it
here on e4 can't really do that Fe Abbas
rook here on C once although it is
controlling this open C file wants to
make sure that it is safe from that pin
so moving back here to b1 and then
Knight to e5 had a few options here
could have maybe played Knight to d4 but
this is going to be a lot worse so it's
always important to look at you know
where you're going to go and what your
opponent can do because after let's say
Knight to d4 which is a huge mistake
y could play pawn to e3 and it gets
extremely tricky now that the Knights
going to have to move it let's say u
comes back here to c6
now the pawn takes on e4 and
it's pretty bad white starting to open
up the game he has both the knight and
the bishop
defending the square here on e4 Black's
going to go down another pawn in
material and he's also allowing white to
open up the game state and not be as
cramped anymore if the knight doesn't
come back to c6 let's say comes to f3
which you know is somewhat tricky but he
could he could try it for funsies sake
Knight takes on f3 could see an exchange
Queen takes here on f3 maybe the Queen
on it takes on d3 just trying to gobble
up some material but Queen takes on b7
Weiss up a huge advantage right here
there's no real way for black to attack
this white should have a pretty easy
game from here so decides to go and play
Knight to e5 and set which is probably
the better move Knight over here to b3
getting ready to position it to the
center of the board
more than likely Knight to d4 at some
points and then that over here to g4
black knows that the Kings side of the
board is his best option to start to
attack his opponent Queen to c2
finalizing the development of white side
the board hasn't really moved his Queen
yet so Queen is c2 and then Bishop down
here to III and first you may look at
and say well you didn't even capture
material on e3 that's a weird move well
the pawns are not going to take because
then Knight takes on e3 traded that
Bishop for the pond but now he's
attacking both the Queen on c2 and the
rook here on f1 and the board States not
really open right now so this is a
pretty good position from black White's
not going to be taking that right now
decides to go ahead and take with the
pawn on e4 says we'll make this trade if
you want it a little bit later but let
me open up the board states where if you
actually do bring your knight down I can
get my queen into a better position so
that's kind of what he's going war with
pawn takes on e4 then the Queen comes
down here to g5 and I think he has a
missed opportunity here Levon Aronian
had Knight takes on f2 which almost
seems like that's what he was going for
with Bishop down here - III couldn't
have just been to bait his opponent to
try to take it because I don't think
White's going to be doing that most of
the time especially the highest level
play so there has to be some sort of
plan
be and I think night 2f2 is that plan if
the rook were to take here on f2 I think
that's fine the bishop is pinning down
this rook it's not really going anywhere
pawn could take on e4 that's fine then
you could see maybe the rook come over
here to F 1 this rooks not going
anywhere because it's pinned down Queen
to c7 getting it more involved into the
game if at any time this King were to
move let's say King H 1 then the bishop
would just take here on f2 it's a really
tricky spot for wife he has to tie up so
much of his major material or else he's
going to end up losing material so I
think the the night taking on f2 was
kind of what black should have been
going for the entire time but instead
decided to play Queen down here to g5
why decides to go ahead and now take
with the pawn on e3 said hey if you want
to go ahead and take the knight on e3
attack both the rook and the Queen
that's fine we're going to have a pretty
active position now that we've opened up
the board say a little bit more so it is
a risk for whites because he's going to
be losing one of his major pieces just
more than likely the rook here on f1 but
black decides to not even go with that
option instead of taking with his Queen
Queen down here to e3 check King over
here to h1 safety for now Queen back 286
pawn to h3 just trying to avoid
checkmate Queen down here to h2 would be
checkmate
Knight to e3 so we do have the fort in
place right now Queen to d2 upon to F
force was starting to put pressure on
his opponents and then Queen or the pawn
takes on f4 first Knight takes down here
on f1 rook takes over here on f1 so we
start to see a lot of exchanges on
boards and this is exactly what white
wants to happen on the board he is up in
material if he could just trade down
towards the endgame
he's going to have a much better in game
so it's an interesting approach from
Levon Aronian he had a very strong
attack and now he started to lose a lot
of his material no longer has any pond
so it's going to be tough for him to get
past all these four pawns on the Kings
side the board he really needs to get
his other
involved have a really strong attack
there's just so much material that white
has to kind of stop that so white should
have kind of a easy in game in my
opinion but you never know at some of
this high level play Bishop takes here
on b3 so it doesn't want to get some of
that material back it's kind of waiting
for blacks to go ahead and take this but
first wanted to go ahead and exchange
some of the pieces on the king's head
aboard for some reason pawn to e5 so
white does have a passed pawn anytime
you have a passed pawn rule number one
is push that forward as fast as possible
just put so much pressure on your
opponent Black is now going to be forced
to use his rooks potentially as Queen to
stop that attack instead of really
putting pressure on his opponent
then why it's going to have a easier in
game not having to worry about any
pressure from black rook a8 - EEE eight
could have also played his F rook to e8
both of those are going to be tough for
him but it had to go and bring his a
rook over since he wasn't doing anything
you with it a knight to e4 then the King
comes up here to h8 King H to Bishop
back here to g8 I don't really like this
from black it kind of waves the white
flag to me Bishop on g8 is about as
defensive as you can get in a spot in
the game where he does not need to be
defensive there's just not a lot of
great options for black could have tried
bishop up here to e6 to stop some of the
attack you know stops pawn to f5 because
he has both the bishop and the rook the
pawn can't push forward at any time so
there's that I decide to go and play
Bishop to g8 pawn to e3 so they're
starting to push the pawn structure a
little bit rook to e6 so stopping the
pawn pushing forward but this pawn is
also a nice little outpost for the
knight Knight comes up here to d6
threatening the pawn on b7 no real way
to hold on to that unless he wants to
bring his rook over here to b8 which is
kind of a mess for black as well
Queen to h4 is going to try and attack
on the Kings side the board just doesn't
have much material to go along with that
Queen Queen to d4 just more centralizing
the White Queen rook here to g6 so
starting an attack
doesn't have too much material rook to
f3 Queen down here to e1 pawn to f5 just
saying yeah your Queens all alone I'm
going to start to attack your rook rook
down here g5 pawn h4 rook here h5 rook
to g3 stopping any sort of Queen and
rook combination here a Bishop down here
East 6th really just looking for
something to open up the door set the
pawn or to take now the rook can get
involved into the game but decided to go
ahead and just take says it doesn't
really matter I don't see a way for you
to actually come down have a perpetual
check or anything Levon Aronian also
could not find a continuation where he
did not lose and so decided in this
position to go ahead and raise on so
congratulations great game for whites so
yon opponent still has a chance to win
the tournament he's half a point off of
the lead right now so going into the
last round this was very important for
him so congratulations
hopefully you guys enjoyed round aids in
a great tournament so far and I will see
you guys tomorrow for round number 9